Speaker 1: Speaking of law and order, radical
Trumpist Republican Congressman Madison Cawthorn
has been charged for driving with no license.
Here's the key word. A second time, North Carolina
Congressman Madison Cawthorn charged with driving
with revoked license for second time. He now has
a court date. Congressman Madison Cawthorn has
been charged with driving with a revoked license,
a misdemeanor that carries up to 20 days in jail.
The 26 year old Republican was pulled over March
3rd in Cleveland County, about an hour and a half
southeast of Asheville by the highway patrol.
Along with the misdemeanor, Cawthorn is facing
two pending citations for speeding in different
counties. Highway Patrol spokesperson Sgt. Markus
beThere said March nine he could confirm that the
three citation numbers are pending matters. The
Cleveland County stop happened around Shelby.
Trooper Tyler Gant saw a 2019 Toyota truck
crossed the center line. Not, you know,
pretty reckless driving. The driver was identified
as David Madison. Cawthorn, I guess, is, I guess,
Madison is his middle name. During the course
of the investigation, it was determined the
driver's license was in a state of revocation.
He doesn't have an actual valid license. He was
charged with driving while license revoked. They
claim to be about law and order, and they're not.
They claim that it's the left that's doing
all the election stuff, but it's actually them
and in particular, and this is not a joke when it
comes to motor vehicle stuff. You would think that
Madison Cawthorn would understand the consequences
of irresponsible driving, unlicensed driving all
this stuff. He's in a wheelchair because of a car
accident he was involved in when he was younger,
in which, if I recall correctly, his friend, the
driver fell asleep, and I'm not even going to
speculate on what that means. Fell asleep can mean
a lot of different things when it comes to traffic
accidents, and he is regularly speeding, crossing
the centerline, driving with no, no valid license.
Guys, come on. It's the double standards and the
hypocrisy. I know they don't care about them,
but at a certain point it's almost like a
skit. They are such hypocrites. No word as
to whether he pulled the Do you know who I am?
Sort of game? But this is a guy who regularly,
you know, to say he's deliberately breaking the
law. We would need to know his state of mind.
But he's at least at minimum, accidentally
breaking it. Remember when he tried to bring
a gun on a plane, he had a gun in his carry
on and he tried to bring it on a plane? Oh,
he forgot where it was. Oh no, it's just
congressman, sir. Responsible Congressman.
Well, if you forget where your gun is, that
doesn't sound like responsible gun ownership. One
of the principles of responsible gun ownership is
you should always know whether the gun is loaded
and you should always know where the gun is.
The gun was in his carry on. He didn't believe,
or he was not aware that it was in his carry on.
That's negligence, but always, Oh no, these are
just it's these are just accidents. Who's going
to who's he going to blame for this one? Antifa.
Black Lives Matter critical race theory. A Joe
Biden socialism or maybe transgender kids or
George Soros. I don't know the party
of personal responsibility. Very quick
to say these were accidents, and certainly
someone else is actually to blame here. So
second time, second time caught driving
without a valid license. Madison Cawthorn.